in 1984 sci-fi classic is finally going
to get the Hollywood treatment but not a
movie
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
movie channel
[Music]
in 1984 William Gibson wrote the
Neuromancer now this book a classic in
sci-fi is considered to be the father of
sci-fi Punk it actually has inspired
several projects thinking like Johnny
manonimik Johnny manominik Johnny
mannumenick Nick
that Keanu Reeves sci-fi Android movie
as well as inspiring an entire genre of
sci-fi now if you are a regular
Sidetrack you'll know that I have a guy
that I speak to that works in Hollywood
and for a certain agency and he gets to
tell me lots and lots of Juicy little
tidbits of information talking to him
about Stargate and the expanse and lots
of other things he happened to mention
this project and this is something I'm
seriously excited about because this is
actually a novel I read as a small boy
and absolutely adored I love things like
Tank Girl and projects like that as well
I do really kind of like the the Punk
theme it kind of inspires me a lot of my
music taste as well if I'm honest so
they have actually attempted to make
this project into a movie lots of times
but it's never quite worked so let's go
back through
epic comics turned it into a graphic
novel Series in 1989 I've actually read
that as well that was very cool
um there was a Commodore 64 right now
you have to be a certain age to remember
that
um I actually had a Commodore of 16 and
then a Commodore 64. I didn't actually
play this game until years afterwards
but it was released in uh the early 90s
I think
um uh I never actually played but what I
did do is I got a version of the game
later that I was over playing the PC so
don't get me wrong not a particularly
good game by today's standards it was
pretty awful but I loved it at the time
the first time they tried to make it
into a movie was back in 2007 Mila
jollovich was going to Star sure I'm not
saying that name right but she would
have actually been Wicked in this movie
one of the main stars is a very sassy
woman character and and I'll tell you a
bit more about the plot in a second but
she would have she it would have worked
oh by the way if you do like the content
please consider hitting the join
important and becoming a fully fledged
side tracker you can also go to
signdashtrack.com and pick marvelous
merchandise all of these little things
really help the channel also if you're
new to the channel like subscribe hit
that Bell notification and share the
video wherever the hell you want
um back in 2012 gfm films try to again
get going with this they actually had a
script that had apparently been done a
few years before and that actually
um William Gibson had had his hand in so
it would have had that touch of
authenticity that as the real sci-fi
fans really love uh Liam Neeson and Mark
Wahlberg were both approached and
potentially interested in filming that
movie but again it never quite got off
the ground
the most current attempt to make this
into a movie was actually very recent in
2017. Deadpool's Tim Miller was going to
direct for Fox and Simon kinberg was
going to produce so
this project and the right to produce
this project have banks around a little
bit but they currently are held by Fox
Now Fox is obviously owned by Disney so
I can feel the
pitter-patter of time little feet
running for the door as we speak because
as soon as anybody says Disney we all
sigh a little bit of a uh God what
they're going to do with that then
but
fox actually does have a pretty good
history of making slightly more crazy
Sci-Fi movies a slightly more cool
Sci-Fi movies
they give this to somebody like Tim
Miller somebody that did such a great
job for me at least with um both
Deadpool movies and if they give it an
rating
now this could be pretty good now the
Neuromancer again has inspired lots of
projects like
um Ghost in the Shell now the most
recent attempt at making Ghost in the
Shell
was Bloody awful they tried to go for
the strange and they tried to respect
the original material a fair bit I
imagine but it just didn't work now
Ghost in the Shell starred Scarlett
Johansson the most memorable bit of that
movie was the bits where Scarlett
Johansson cgi'd was basically naked
um other than that the film was actually
quite forgettable quite hard to follow
and just not particularly well made
now tell you a little bit about the plot
for the Neuromancer so it's based in
China City in Japan Henry case did this
washed up hacker and he gets actually
caught trying to steal from his boss so
his punishment they damaged his central
nervous system which means he can no
longer upload himself to The Matrix they
might have to change that name I don't
know who quite knows the right to that
um which is the basically a worldwide VR
system now already you can probably name
five movies off the top of the head
they've been inspired by this um I'm
thinking like ready player one that's
Bill big movie a couple years ago it's
very similar to the plot of this on this
one last job he's talked into working
with Molly Millions who Mila jollovich I
imagine would have played in the earlier
attempt to make this into a movie uh
they were going to steal this
um like a ROM drive now the movie goes
on from there there's lots of highs
losses there's a lot of really like um
stuff that makes you stop and think it
gets very crazy in a few places
it's going to be a very very difficult
movie to make
but what am I being told about the
current state of this project
well they're not going to make a movie
anymore
what I'm being told is that fox really
want to get this on Disney plus and Hulu
in the United States and it will be a
short streaming miniseries of maybe
about eight episodes now on Disney
plusson Hulu Fox is allowed to push
limits a fair bit I'm thinking things
like American Horror and and shows like
that there was that Marvel series which
I've never forgotten the name of and
we've set back in the 60s the main guy
was uh Professor X's dad
can't remember the poster was wicked it
was his brain going I'll put a little
note down here telling you what it was
called but anyway
um that really pushed limits of what was
felt quite Arty actually it was quite
boring to watch actually places
um but still overall for me a complete
Triumph I actually think on that network
if they're allowed to be creative and if
Disney doesn't try to force them to go
in a certain direction which they tend
to do sometimes then this could be a
really wicked TV series
but get in the comments and tell me what
you think is this a project that you
ever read when you were a kid did you
read the graphic novels or you know play
the video game yourself
interesting tip here they actually tried
to turn this into an opera it nearly got
made
um it was it even had a premiere date
but then it never quite happened
I can't imagine how the hell they turned
this into an opera but it would have
been spectacular anyway
but nice to say against it comes to tell
me what you think if you are new to the
Channel please like subscribe hit that
Bell notification really helps us out
and if you enjoy the content please
consider becoming a fully fledged side
tracker hit the join button hit it now
as always guys please stay safe I'll see
you next time
[Music]